[Musique]
louis saillant est un mec ce commando
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi la barre est parfaitement
légitime pour qu'on parle de jay liste
on parle de gens qui recrutent des
enfants on parle de gens qui sont d'une
barbarie extrême serre est un terreau
qui peut favoriser
l'extension du terrorisme ne faut pas
imaginer qu'il suffit simplement d'avoir
un pays pauvre pour que l'islam c'est à
dire là qui sont embrigadés ils ont été
séduits ils ont été manipulés et
d'autres qui agissent de manière
parfaitement consciente et lucide je
respecterai toujours
l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
[Musique]
nairobi
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque jour du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce lundi 20 septembre
la france qui était traité de façon
inacceptable
ce soir la présidente de la commission
européenne sort de son silence un jour
après la décision de l'australie
d'annuler le contrat d'achat de sous
marins français
une rupture au profit de navires
américains hormis cette déclaration de
refus la vente d'art leyen paris se
retrouve bien isolé sur la scène
internationale
une affaire qui continue d'agacer la
classe politique française certains
opposants pointent du doigt une trahison
de trois puissants alliés de l'otan et
remettent même en question l'engagement
de la france au sein de l'organisation
soixante ans après la fin de la guerre
d'algérie emmanuel macron demande pardon
aux harkis au nom de la france une
première pour un chef d'état français le
chef d'état qui lance un gros chantier
de reconnaissance et de réparation pour
tous les hommes qui ont combattu aux
côtés de l'armée française des harkis
abandonnés par paris est victime de
représailles en algérie
qu'à 21h place à notre désormais rendez
vous qu'en pensent les français ce soir
la parole est donnée aux travailleurs du
secteur de la restauration grandes
victimes de la pandémie de kobe 19 nous
irons à la rencontre de jérémy
chicheportiche propriétaire d'un bar
restaurant à melun en région parisienne
ce patron 1 souffre de la mise en place
du pass sanitaire une situation
difficile qui risque encore de durer
puisque un projet de loi visant à faire
pour roger se passe est en réflexion
même s'il pourrait être à d'autres
adapté à l'échelle locale
[Musique]
après avoir rappelé ses ambassadeurs à
canberra et washington la france annule
donc une rencontre prévue cette semaine
entre ministres de la défense français
et britannique
la crise des sous marins ne passe pas
par imi hors d'un jeu face à l'alliance
entre les états unis l'australie et le
royaume uni cela s'est concrétisé par
l'annulation par l'australie du contrat
d'achat de sous marins français au
profit de navires américains et
britanniques à propulsion nucléaire
exécutif attendons des explications
grégoire douce et avec sébastien zaba
après le temps de la colère celui des
clarifications dans les prochains jours
les présidents macro hebeisen vont se
parler au téléphone à la demande du
locataire de la maison blanche la colère
froide exprimé dans les médias par le
chef de la diplomatie française jean
yves le drian laisse désormais place aux
demandes d'explication communiqué par le
porte parole du gouvernement gabriella
talent la question des conséquences de
cette rupture de contrat n'en est qu'à
ses débuts nous devons d'abord en
discuter avec nos partenaires et voir
comment il compte en sortir il ya un
certain nombre de clauses et de
procédures dans le contrat donc il est
clair qu'une compensation sera
nécessaire ce travail commence
maintenant et nous aurons besoin de
clarifications et d'explications
mercredi dernier la rupture du contrat
du siècle par l'australie au profit des
états unis a débouché sur une décision
inédite de l'elysée rappelé ses
ambassadeurs à washington et canberra
conséquence directe une confiance
sérieusement entamées entre la france et
son allié historique les etats unis
outre atlantique justement la prudence
est de mise dans un communiqué n'être
price porte parole de la diplomatie
américaine a rappelé l'attachement de
washington à la france nous comprenons
leur position et nous sommes au courant
de leur intention de rappeler
l'ambassadeur etienne à paris pour des
consultations la france est un
partenaire essentiel est notre plus
ancien allié et nous accordons la plus
haute importance à nos relations
hasard du calendrier les chefs des
diplomaties française et américaine se
retrouveront la semaine prochaine à
l'assemblée générale de l'onu une
occasion d'aborder ensemble leurs
différends le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson s'est exprimé
dimanche soir alors qu'il était en route
pour new york il a sorti le grand jeu en
déclarant que les liens de son pays avec
la france sont indéracinable il a
insisté sur la relation très amicale et
d'une immense importance qui unit paris
et londres de son côté l'australie a
défendu sa décision pour le premier
ministre scott morrison le made in
france n'est pas la hauteur des besoins
de son pays
alors où je vais embarquer pour aller
voir nos amis aux états unis et y
rencontrer beaucoup d'autres personnes
venant d'europe du royaume-uni et des
etats-unis il s'agit avant tout
d'assurer la sécurité des australiens il
s'agit toujours de s'assurer que les
intérêts souverains de l'australie passe
en premier afin que les australiens
puissent vivre en paix
à l'origine de cette discorde un contrat
faramineux signé en 2016 entre la france
et l'australie 56 milliards d'euros pour
la fourniture de 12 sous marin à
propulsion diesel un accord aux enjeux
économiques et stratégiques majeures
mais tout cela a volé en éclat lorsque
mercredi canberra a annoncé la rupture
de ce contrat en or massif au même
moment washington a présenté un large
partenariat de sécurité avec l'australie
et le royaume uni dans l'inde au
pacifique un véritable coup dans le dos
selon les mots du chef de la diplomatie
française il ya donc une retrait des
troupes américaines d'afghanistan sans
concertation avec les alliés de l'otan
il ya désormais cette nouvelle crise
diplomatique entre membres de
l'organisation le gouvernement français
qui ne peut visiblement pas compter sur
ses alliés justement après cette
trahison dans les faire des sous marins
l'idée d'un retrait français d'autant
fait son chemin dans la classe politique
française de xavier bertrand en passant
par jean luc mélenchon ou fabien roussel
à jordan bardella alors la france
doit-elle quitté l'otan c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en débattre ce soir
club blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir que manche
maison merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés un petit peu plus loin on skype en
direct avec nous caroline galak terros
géopolitologue présidente du think tank
géo pragma bonsoir caroline des lacs
terrasse merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
première réaction vous qualifieriez de
quoi d'humiliation ce qui vient de se
passer pour notre pays
c'est à moi de me poser la question
c'est balisé moi je vous regarder mais
c'est vrai que vous ne me voyez pas d'un
coup ils effectivement grand inga lactée
ans excusez moi non je vais donc oui
bien sûr c'est une humiliation
c'est surtout la dernière manifestation
est bien de respect dans lequel on nous
tient c'est la manifestation d'un
déclassement stratégie parce que je
pense qu'il faut quand même on se
finisse par se poser les questions on ne
veut pas se poser des classements
stratégique et surtout c'est une pierre
agression
contre notre autonomie industriels en
matière d'armement donc on a
effectivement beaucoup de fil à retordre
après cette décision qui était en plus
enfin tout a été fait tout a été en
manche et bien avant même les dernières
les derniers contacts entre le président
bailon et le président macron donc on
est là dans un camouflet mais qui
correspond à j'allais dire à une
stratégie de deux longues de longue
haleine et de ça fait longtemps que
c'est que c'est le cas donc là on a
juste des signes des signes qui sont
interprétées dont il faut tirer
certaines conséquences et on va y venir
évidemment sur ses conséquences mais
tout d'abord sur le diagnostic caroline
galec terros moody agression camouflet
pour la première fois en tout cas que le
branche maison la france a rappelé son
ambassadeur aux états unis ça veut dire
quoi vous qui êtes ex-ambassadeur ça
chauffe c'est quoi c'est le moins qu'on
puisse faire je voulais vous dire c'est
très grave évidemment ça n'est peut-être
pas tant que ça c'est sûr nous
symbolique naturellement puisque les
ambassades continue de fonctionner on
est heureux devient chargé d'affaires
d'ailleurs les américains ont un chargé
d'affaires depuis que monsieur trump
n'est plus président puisque le nouvel
ambassadeur n'a pas pris encore ses
fonctions mais évidemment sur le plan
symbolique c'est une mesure très lourde
et la france ne l'avait jamais fait il y
avait des élus des états unis macron l'a
fait vis-à-vis de l'italie quant à un
ministre venait discuter avec les gilets
jaunes tous les samedis il a fait aussi
vis-à-vis de la turquie lorsque monsieur
erdogan avait tenu des propos insultant
vis-à-vis du président de la république
mais c'est rarissime bon alors
effectivement je pense que à part cela
il ya sans doute d'autres moyens
envisagés
parce que faire pression sur les états
unis et sur l'australie le mal est fait
faire pression pour quoi faire puisque
le mal est fait d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses nous n'avons pas après notre
ambassade à vous notre ambassadrice au
royaume uni je pense que monsieur
d'origine sonne et vexée que l'on se le
tiennent pour quantité négligeable
finalement on n'a même pas jugé utile de
prendre la moindre mesure à son égard or
c'est lui qui a été la cheville ouvrière
vous croyez justement on le prend pour
une quantité négligeable sans doute il
ya beaucoup de différents sur
l'application du break site puisqu'il
implique toujours pas l' annexe irlande
du nord pas de contrôle sur les produits
qui rentre en héros en irlande du nord
et puis par ailleurs nos pêcheurs ne
peuvent toujours pas aller à gérer c'est
enfin il ya beaucoup de sujets de
différends et qu'ils nous accusent de
lâcher les migrants sur les côtes
britanniques donc peut-être qu'il
fallait pas non plus ajouté d'autres
d'autres difficultés mais effectivement
il faut envisager sans doute d'autres
mesures et en fonction de l'analyse
qu'on a de la réalité de ce qui vient de
se passer il ya naturellement la faire
des sous marins qui est une affaire très
grave mais aussi le fait que la vérité
vient d'éclater c'est à dire pour les
américains l'inde au pacifique la
fameuse stratégie indo pacifique dans
tous les secteurs discutent depuis
quatre ou cinq ans et bien pour monsieur
ben hayden c'est une alliance militaire
dirigée par les états unis pour que les
membres achètent uniquement du matériel
militaire américain et qui est dirigé
contre la chine bon au moins c'est clair
alors à partir de cela la france peut se
déterminer parce que il ya d'autres pays
de la région qui ne sont pas d'accord
l'un ne va pas rentrer dans cette
alliance le japon et la corée du sud ont
des alliances direct avec les états unis
mais qui porte sur d'autres d'autres
côtes d'autres considérations
la nouvelle zélande ne veux pas entrer
dans cet accord parce qu'elle n'accepte
pas dans ces ports les navires à
propulsion nucléaire
par conséquent il est possible que ces
noyaux belliqueux
reste finalement tout seul en tout cas
pour jean yves le drian c'est clairement
une rupture de confiance majeure avec
washington pour la classe politique
française on disait c'est un échec une
humiliation mondiales donc il faut tirer
les conséquences
regardez tout d'abord cette réaction
celle du patron de la région des hautes
france candidat à la présidentiel xavier
bertrand
la question de savoir si pour les
américains nous comptons aussi ou si
nous sommes en deuxième division si la
réponse ne nous satisfait pas ce soit
mettre sur la table la question de la
participation de la france au
commandement intégré de l'otan il ya
deux idées en danse que véhicule ou
xavier bertrand justement la france qui
ne compte pas vraiment au sud est des
états unis et bien sûr la sortie de
l'otan on va commencer par les prendre
dans l'ordre clairement caroline
gaillac terros la france quantité
négligeable
pour les états unis il ya plus de
doubles là je crois que c'est clair je
me demande d'ailleurs comment on peut
avoir des doutes depuis déjà des années
c'est cette saynète c'est clair et on
voit bien qu'il ya une continuité dans
la politique extérieure américaine qui
va bien au delà des républicains et
démocrates il faut pas oublier que je
n'ai au conservatisme est né du côté
démocrate de l'échiquier politique
américain donc là nous sommes dans un
contexte en fait de repos la risation
agressive et d'instrumentalisation aux
prises en main prêts nets de l'otan à
cette fin recolonisation bien sûr contre
la chine et il faut mettre en ordre de
marche les massot donc il ya des vassaux
de premier rang là bas c'est net c'est
laisser les files dont on a assez parlé
c'est un vieux pat et qui est toujours
très opérateurs opérationnel et puis il
y a bien sûr alors les australiens mais
ils vont faire une mauvaise affaire je
pense que c'est aussi très intéressant
de regarder ce qu'ils vont gagner alors
à leur soumission parce que finalement
ils vont avoir en acceptant le le marché
américain est un chantage sur le n vous
êtes avec nous vous êtes contre nous si
vous êtes contre nous attentions vous
fait certes la majeure partie de notre
commerce avec la chine met donc on
essaie de les faire basculer pour qu'ils
ne se tournent plus du tout vers la
chine donc là il ya eu ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que ce contrat du
siècle qui datent 2016 dès sa conclusion
déjà dès l'appel d'offres légales
beaucoup de lobbying anti français
notamment qu'à part des allemands qui
sont qui tiennent toujours la corde
d'une certaine façon est plus que jamais
d'ailleurs en europe mais contre nous ce
qui est assez regrettable mais enfin et
il ya eu surtout un lobbying intense
contre ce contrat donc aujourd'hui je
dirais et comme comme la ti
l'ambassadeur blanche façon c'est trop
tard la messe est dite donc il faut que
nous nous prenions des mesures pour
montrer on ne nous marche pas dessus
impunément que nous aussi nous sommes
une puissance à ne pas s'y fier que nous
avons des intérêts des ans mais nous ne
sommes pas dans une position belliqueuse
rigide que ce soit vis-à-vis de la chine
contre la chine roux d'ailleurs contre
la russie ce qui est la nouvelle posture
de l'otan donc c'est ça le contexte
c'est c'est ça c'est ça qui est
important et nous devons nous décider
quelles sont nos intérêts ça ne veut pas
dire quitter les états unis pour aller
vers la chine ça veut dire partir de
nous
refourguer une diplomatie et une
politique étrangère qui soit autre chose
que du pur atlantis est juste là à
attendre n'est ce pas qu'on nous
considère quand nous recevons des
preuves toujours plus nombreuses que ce
n'est pas le cas on cherche surtout à
enterrer bien sûr tous les rêves
complètement utopique et naïf de
d'autonomie stratégiques européennes
mais on ferme on cherche surtout à notre
à la france quel intérêt elle aussi à
rentrer dans le rang et vite sinon eh
bien elle leur fera les frais je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse laisser faire
cela club blanche maison justement à
reggio bagdad on l'a vu faire du vélo
dans le delaware ce week-end pas
d'ailleurs un titre de presse aux
etats-unis alors que nous on parle que
de ça
un certain chanteur aznavour disait il
faut savoir quitter la table quand
l'amour est desservie quelle est la
stratégie d'une france qui est
aujourd'hui boudé
par son ancien allié je dirais américain
qu'il est toujours mais enfin c'est vrai
que c'est de plus en plus
discutable quand on voit les derniers
développements de l'actualité
sur le temps je note que personne ne
propose que la france quitte l'alliance
atlantique par conséquent ce qui est
proposé par certains candidats à
l'élection présidentielle aujourd'hui
c'est de quitter les organes militaires
intégrés c'est à dire d'en revenir à ce
qu'un effet le général de gaulle à
l'époque où il avait décidé du retrait
de la france les organes militaires
intégrés mais à l'époque ça avait
beaucoup plus loin puisqu'il y avait
beaucoup de bases américaines en france
dont elle devait partir il avait le
siège de l'otan en france à la porte
dauphine et a dû partir et c'était
évidemment un coup de tonnerre personne
ne pensait que la france était capable
de faire cela et aujourd'hui
effectivement on peut se demander si
dans le fond emmanuel macron qui ne
déteste pas les prises de position un
peu transgressif qui a dix qui a déclaré
la mort cérébrale de l'otan dans le fond
pourrait être tenté par cette décision
mais il aurait tout contre lui
l'ensemble de l'establishement militaire
et l'establishment militaire ne veut pas
quitter l'otan parce que d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de nos opérations en
afrique dépendent de l'infrastructure de
l'otan notamment en matière logistique
en matière de renseignement donc le
sujet va être discutée et en effet ceux
ci doit aussi être évoquée entre mâcon
et le président joe biden puisqu'ils
vont se parler probablement demain et
que en tout cas macron fera un discours
en vidéoconférence al'onu demain dans ce
discours il va probablement dire il va
lancer un appel à la paix et dire que
nous ne sommes pas là pour monter des
alliances contre la chine ou contre
quiconque d'ailleurs mais probablement
que joe biden va dire que ce qu'il a
fait avec l'australie c'est pour le
maintien de la paix et c'est pas du tout
agressif vis-à-vis de la chine parce que
c'est comme ça que les américains
présentent leurs affaires
clément caroline galak terros intérêts
ou non pour la france de quitter l'otan
parce que oui des candidats à la
présidentielle le demandent ils sont un
certain nombre aujourd'hui
de tous les bords si j'ose dire en
d'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche en
passant par la droite au centre
non il s'agit pas pour moi il ne s'agit
pas de quitter l'otan ne serait ce que
pour savoir encore ce qui se passe en
revanche les organes militaires intégrés
oui certainement
non seulement au plan symbolique mais
aussi parce que c'est aussi par ces
mécanismes là que la france est entraîné
dans une posture collective de
bellicisme hanté chinois qui ne
correspond pas du tout une autre vision
du monde qui s'ils voulaient 7,7 pour
les américains veulent de nouveaux
reculs avisé le monde en deux en deux
temps avec nous qu'on nous les bons les
méchants les blanc et noirs ça suffit
c'est plus comme ça du tout on est dans
un monde police entré avec de grands
ensembles régionaux avec des puissances
importante danser ensemble et nous la
france nous avons à aa à pouvoir faire
entendre notre voix qui est une voie
d'équilibré qui n'est pas du tout une
voix de 2,2 bellick aux hits et donc à
laquelle pour laquelle nous n'avons
aucun intérêt
aucun intérêt clamant oui aucun intérêt
pour vous aussi nom de la raison il faut
obéir et arrêter de subir
trop et ont subi un peu trop oui je
pense que en effet il arrive qu'on on se
range dans le courant dans le mainstream
comme on dit à l'otan et qu'on peut
toujours dire non à l'otan puisque les
décisions sont prises par consensus si
quelqu'un a le courage de dire non et de
dire non aux états unis et bien la
décision n'est pas prise peut-être
faut-il le faire de temps à autre mais
ce que je voulais dire c'est que dans
les circonstances actuelles ce qu'il
faut surtout faire c'est reconstruire
une doctrine française de l'inde au
pacifique qu'ils soient pas la doctrine
américaine et la doctrine française de
l'inde au pacifique qui ressemble un
petit peu à celle de l'inde à celle des
pays comme singapour comme la malaisie
comme des pays avec lesquels nous avons
des accords de coopération stratégique
même comme le vietnam c'est d'avoir en
effet un ensemble d'accords avec des
coopérations sur mesure dans chaque cas
mais pas une alliance militaire et je
pense que c'est ce qui va être si je
dois être démontrée dans les prochains
mois qu'il est possible de monter
quelque chose de ce genre peut-être
est-ce mais là aussi on peut il faut pas
désespérer de l'ordre n'est ce pas
l'europe a publié sa propre vision de
l'inde au pacifique manque de chance
c'était le jour monsieur byden parlait
alors effectivement personne n'a entendu
ce que disait madame von der leyen est
ce que disait le président du conseil
européen c'était probablement très
modérée enfin on l'a on l'a tous lui
mais c'était effectivement quelque chose
qui ressemblait un peu à la conception
française de l'inde au pacifique sans
naturellement le volet militaire puisque
l'union européenne n'a pas de volet
militaire et que le volet militaire et
l'hymne national est pour nous nous
vendons des rafales nous vendons des
sous marins à l'inde
nous pourrions vendre davantage nous
avons vendu 36 rafale qui ont été livrés
cette année à l'inde c'est très
important nous construisons six
sous-marins scorpène actuellement en 1 3
sont en service peut-être pourrait-on et
les indiens le souhaitent dans des
trains l'australien elle annonce d'un
gros contrat aujourd'hui paradoxalement
absolument et peut-être pourrait-on
aussi que
rehausser une coopération militaire qui
ne dit pas vraiment son nom avec le
vietnam parce que les dames on forme des
gens aux opérations de maintien de la
paix de l'onu on forme des médecins
militaires on n'a pas plus loin parce
qu'on a peur que tout fait là la chine
il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui la mer de
chine la la le conflit en mer de chine
du sud était précisément un conflit
entre la chine et le vietnam car oui le
caractère aux ouvriers réagir aux propos
de club band maison non mais c'est à
dire nos trains c'est merveilleux mais
ces 300 millions donc cesser c'est
formidable c'est une fête une petite
gnagne est et nous avons pris l'habitude
de ramasser les miettes et de nous en
contenter donc il est pour moi pour moi
s'il voulait il est il est clair que
maintenant il faut il faut complètement
changé de portage d'un point de français
du point de vue la politique étrangère
française qui doit être fondée sur de
toutes autres bases ensuite quand
l'ambassade en planches maison dit
qu'effectivement l'europe n'a pas de
volet militaire
oui sauf que nous avons un président qui
nous explique qu'il va y aura une
autonomie stratégique européenne ce qui
est une pure utopie dans le traité de
lisbonne il est clair il est dit
clairement et simplement que c'est
l'otan le volet militaire de l'europe
donc larmes on est dans une reprise en
main que nous avons à mon avis nous
français absolument aucun intérêt aucune
raison de subir de reprise en main
militaire
du studio comment dirais-je très très
brutale qui veut réimposer de nouveau
une vision complètement antagoniste du
monde avec un leader du monde dit je ne
sais quoi libre peut-être
vis-à-vis d'autres pays qui auraient
d'autres intérêts et aujourd'hui c'est
la chine voilà je pense simplement que
il faut pas oublier vraiment que les les
australiens la ont été soumis eux aussi
un chantage pour prendre cette décision
ça va leur coûter plus cher ça va être
plus longue - deux sous-marins ça va
être très compliqué ils vont être
complètement soumis à une dépendance
technologique et en matière nucléaire
vis-à-vis des etats-unis donc on est
dans ce renversement éclat vont
franchement quelle quelle est notre
intérêt à nous qui avons des possessions
en indo pacifique qui avant une capacité
politique propre en indo pacifique et
des intérêts à défendre et qui nous ne
sommes absolument pas opposé aux chinois
en indo pacifique donc je ne vois pas
pourquoi l'otan qui est en train
d'étendre son spectre parce que l'otan
n'est plus seulement une organisation
militaire il est de plus en plus d'une
organisation à spectre politique globale
ça va jusqu'à l'afrique naturellement
mais ça va de plus en plus maintenant en
indo pacifique ce n'est pas notre
intérêt de participer à ce type
d'opération qui seront qui seront
montées comme des opérations de pure
coercition de pure pression et de pur
chantage la france est une puissance
d'équilibré négation merci en tout cas
tous les deux caroline leguellec terros
d'avoir été avec nous claude branche
maison sur ce plateau et l'annulation de
ce contrat d'armement en tous les cas
avec la france n'est pas une première en
2018 déjà la suisse avait préféré se
tourner vers les états unis et précision
en images avec françois xavier lambert
malgré ses performances reconnues sur le
marché international de la défense
l'industrie française de l'armement doit
aussi faire face à des échecs parfois
même avec des pays proches comme ce fut
le cas avec la suisse en 2018 ce pays
cherche à remplacer sa flotte aérienne
vieillissante et lance donc un appel
d'offres le f-35 américain le rafale
français et l'eurofighter typhoon sont
en compétition
si aucun contrat avec la france n'est
officialisé le ministère suisse de la
défense a donc ouvert des discussions
avec plusieurs industriels dont le
français dassault fabricant du rafale
mais selon paris ces négociations
et qu'une façade car le gouvernement
helvète avait déjà fait son choix
en effet en juin dernier le gouvernement
suisse opte finalement pour l'avion
américain et comment 36 f 35a lockheed
martin le montant de ce contrat
s'élèverait à 6 milliards de francs
suisses soit près de 5 milliards et demi
d'euros la décision de la suisse aurait
alors irrité paris selon la presse
helvète cette dernière avance qu'un
rendez vous entre emmanuel macron et le
président de la confédération suisse guy
parmelin prévue en novembre prochain
aurait été annulée en raison du
mécontentement de la france une
information démentie par l'elysée
cela n'a jamais été annulée et encore
moins pour les raisons évoquées le
président a confirmé le principe de la
rencontre début 2021 les suisses ont
rapidement proposé une date en novembre
et nous avions répondu que nous
regarderions la date n'a pas été calée
pour le moment dassault aviation et le
rafale avait déjà connu une déconvenue
avec un autre pays frontaliers de la
france en 2018 la belgique a aussi
choisi de commander des f 35 au lieu du
rafale bruxelles a passé une commande de
34 avions de chasse américains pour une
valeur estimée à 3,6 milliards d'euros
malgré ces marchés perdus face aux états
unis l'armement français continuent de
bien s'exporter à l'étranger en 2021 la
grèce la croatie et l'egypte ont ainsi
décidé d'acquérir des dizaines de
rafales à la france la finlande pourrait
suivre leur exemple
et le royaume-uni prendra part lui aussi
au nouvel accord avec l'australie d'où
le malaise évidemment on la ministre la
défense florence parly devait rencontrer
à londres son homologue britannique ben
wallace mais il n'ira pas en s'envolant
pour les états unis le premier ministre
britannique a tenu à rassurer paris avec
une déclaration d'amour à la france
ce partenariat n'est en aucun cas
destinée à être un jeu à somme nulle il
n'est pas destiné à être exclu en ce
n'est pas quelque chose dont qui que ce
soit
doit s'inquiéter et en particulier pas
nos amis français notre amour pour la
france étant des 20,6 nabeul et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct depuis
liverpool au royaume uni avec francesco
rizzuto professeur de droit européen
doyen université de l'hiver tout
l'europe c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
bonsoir francesco rizzuto merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
les deux pays ont une relation très
amicale ans c'est ce qu'a déclaré le
premier ministre boris johnson à bord de
l'avion qui l'emmenait à new york encore
des mots toujours des mots qu'en est il
vraiment
et
bien sûr des histoires intéressantes
landes la relation entre londres et
paris entre londres et bruxelles ne se
porte pas bien du tout une
hutte wishful thinking 80 il se fait des
rêves
ça veut dire quoi que la relation ne
cesse de se détériorer depuis le break
citant le divorce avec l'union
européenne autant de sujets
de divergence qui se multiplient
tout à fait c'est auprès xi un problème
de droits d'achat dans la manche qui est
toujours en cours
l'un d'eux nous avons un problème avec
londres crime accuse paris et feront pas
contrôler ses frontières afin que cette
sorte que les gens franchissent chaque
jour maman chanteuse
elle veut récupérer le contrôle de ses
frontières c'est qui est assez risible
et il je le problème 22 la france
l'aurait mis qui serait le face à des
états unis donc je pense que la
situation pourrait paraître au pire il
ya également le problème de l'irlande du
nord
même si l'union européenne a donné un
peu de mou faut donc les relations ne se
porte pas bien fort que c'est ce qu'on
rit d'auto clairement cette affaire de
sous marins pour vous c'est une
illustration des conséquences du bric
sites au royaume-uni autonome qui
renforce son alliance avec son ennemi
historique les états unis
'cela ne fait aucun doute
ah ouais faire d'économie scellé par
très important pour eux de pelé il
s'agit d'une démonstration à l'attention
des sketches et juge que le
royaume uni et les etats unis ont une
relation spéciale que la france qualifie
de relations de fatalité d'une langue de
state
le royer venu vers midi
entre les états unis aient voulu burke a
le pouvoir
de tous les clichés n'importe qui
d'autre et l'australie c'est un accord
entre l'australie et les états unis et
le royaume uni c'est la troisième roue
nous sommes loyaux
bien sûr je le travaille aussi pour
notre propre incurie une bévue mais il
ya le territoire français dans le
pacifique évoluent
donc c'est du marketing
une décision qui est bien plus profonde
que cela
en europe apparaît effectivement il ya
un problème use de
france
joue un rôle très important par exemple
en afrique la france sorte en elle-même
n'a pas un très gros poids est alors un
cercle la colère de
paris
elle est faible
et parce que les autres pays européens
le souhaitera que politique de défense
commune un finira par se sont arrachés
c'est le lait que le calcul fait à
washington comme à londres et vous
disiez le royaume uni qui est dans cette
affaire peut-être une forme de deux
troisième roue effectivement la france
ne s'attaque pas vraiment au royaume uni
dans cette affaire
l'union européenne dénonce d'ailleurs ce
soir à l'instant un manque de loyauté
des états unis a dit charles michel mais
elle ne s'adresse jamais à londres ça
veut dire quoi c'est une manière de dire
comme le disait l'ambassadeur un peu
blanche maison tout à leur ex
ambassadeur c'est une quantité
négligeable on vous parle même plus
le royaume uni dans le cadre de cet
accord
effectivement la crème sur le gâteau
afin de donner l'impression que cet
accord est globale et respectable pour
le résoudre il est important d'en faire
partie car cela nous rapproche de joe
biden qui n'était pas du tout un ami
boris johnson donc effectivement c'est
une forme d'allégeance
boris klein effectivement est un petit
joueur et la france a raison de se
concentrer sur les actions
mais nous parlons ici de tout l'été
international le plus grand acteur ce
sont les états unis
si la france réussit à mobiliser les
autres acteurs plusieurs européens si
elle
réussit à développer une politique
autonome alors cela pourrait changer
déséquilibre mais pour le non ce n'est
pas le cas
insultant de considérer que londres et
le var
meetic c'est une bonne approche
les etats unis ont pris ces décisions
qui ont décidé d'appuyer d'asseoir leur
contrôle sur la région du pacifique
europe l'équilibré des pouvoirs est un
peu différent et voilà pourquoi
touristes jansson prétend que tout va
bien que la france aujourd'hui on en
parlait il ya un instant à certains
politiques français souhaite mettre sur
la table la question de la participation
de la france au commandement intégré de
l'otan qu'elle serait dans cette affaire
le regarder des du royaume uni sur ce
point sur cette problématique
serait de préserver le temps neuves dans
l'union européenne et qu'il ne faut pas
ça fait que l'otan en tant que mécanisme
de défense contre les ennemis de
l'europe parfois très proches
les britanniques ne veulent surtout pas
punis mais ce qui reste de l'otan en ce
temps que forces de défense stratégique
européen
s'attaquer à l'otan en europe car cela
aurait un impact sur les intérêts
puissants sécuritaire botanique les
français de rester dans le temps il doit
pas être attaqués
cela n'est pas en question de temps car
le départ des etats-unis là aussi c'est
une question soit pour les américains
le grand lecteur tracy vannes 6 et
l'allemagne
sauf si les allemands décident de
soutenir la france
sont trop puissants
pour qu'on puisse les ignorer ou les
contrecarrer
merci beaucoup frotté avec nos
professeurs de droit européen à
l'université des chill merci à vous
d'accord usa australie qui fait aussi
réagir la corée du nord ce lundi une
alliance qui pourrait déclencher une
course aux armements nucléaires selon
pyongyang un accord entre canberra et
washington qui nous plaît pas non plus à
pékin une crise des sous marins qui
s'invite aussi à l'onu qui ouvre donc
aujourd'hui son assemblée générale
annuelle mais tin romagne
se dirige-t-on vers une nouvelle guerre
froide
c'est en tout cas la crainte d'antonio
guterres est ce le secrétaire général
des nations unies les conséquences de la
rupture d'un important contrat de
commandes de sous marins français par
l'australie continue de se faire sentir
car la volonté de canberra et de
washington de renforcer leur alliance
face à la chine ravive les tensions avec
les états unis antonio gutiérrez
prévient il faut à tout prix éviter une
nouvelle guerre froide qui serait plus
périlleuse que celle qui opposa
américains et soviétiques
les relations entre la chine et les
états unis sont aujourd'hui en plein
dysfonctionnements depuis le début
lorsque je dialogue avec nos amis
américains et nos amis chinois jeudi
toujours écouter vous avez des systèmes
politiques différents vous avez des
points de vue différents sur le nombre
de même il ya inévitablement des
domaines sur lesquels il y aura une
confrontation
et puis bien sûr en partant de là il y
aura tôt ou tard de stratégie militaire
et géopolitique avec tous les dangers
que cela représente
il ya donc un domaine de confrontation
enfin domaines de coopération un domaine
de négociations sérieuses parce qu'il ya
des problèmes complexes sur la table à
la fois en matière de commerce et de
technologie malheureusement aujourd'hui
il n'y a que de la confrontation il ne
faut rétablir des relations qui
fonctionne entre ces deux puissances
between the two worlds sous la
présidence de trump les griefs entre les
etats-unis et la chine étaient surtout
économiques et commerciaux l'arrivée à
la maison blanche d'un joe biden moins
belliqueux laissait augurer un
réchauffement des relations entre
washington et pékin mais cette alliance
avec l'australie prouve le contraire et
n'est pas du tout du goût de l' empire
du milieu les etats-unis et l'australie
sont en train de se liguer contre la
chine au nom de leurs propres intérêts
géopolitiques
ils ont délibérément dénigrer la chine
se sont immiscés dans les affaires
intérieures de la chine comme ils ont
semé la discorde entre les pays de la
région nous condamnons fortement et
rejetons fermement cela
les états unis et l'australie devrait
suivre les tendances du développement
contemporain respecter les aspirations
communes des pays de la région et vous
non c'est à leur concept obsolète de
guerre froide et de jeu à somme nulle il
devrait considérer correctement le
développement de la chine cesser de
s'immiscer dans les affaires intérieures
de la chine et cesser de faire des
vagues dans la région asie pacifique
sing
sing for all à un autre pays d'asie a
vivement critiqué l'alliance australie
etats unis la corée du nord le contrat
américain signé avec l'australie
pourrait déclencher selon pyongyang une
course à l'armement nucléaire dans une
région où les tensions sont déjà
multiple
c'est dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale c'est législatives en
russie le parti au pouvoir russie unie
est arrivé en tête de ce scrutin devant
les communistes avec plus de 46% des
voix selon des résultats provisoires
c'est un peu moins qu'en 2016 les
résultats définitifs sont attendus ce
vendredi des législatives étalées sur
trois jours avec 108 millions
d'électeurs appelés à renouveler les 450
députés de la douma la chambre basse du
parlement
la correspondance à moscou devait ragots
le président russe a remercié la
population pour sa participation lors de
législatives pour lui cela témoigne du
fait que les russes ont une attitude
responsable vis-à-vis de la composition
du parlement je vous propose d'écouter
son crise l'europe progressé gagnant je
voudrais adresser des remerciements
particuliers
bien sûr aux citoyens de la russie merci
pour votre confiance chers amis pour
votre implication en effet un taux de
participation de 51% même supérieure à
51% est beaucoup plus élevé que les 40
7% et quelques des élections précédentes
étaient
presque 52 % c'est le taux de
participation aux législatives russes
selon la présidente de la commission
centrale électorale et l'open firova en
scorant progression de 4 points par
rapport à celle de 2016 qui avait attiré
48 % des électeurs russes cinq partis
politiques ont gagné leur place dans la
chambre basse du parlement russe il
s'agit de russie unie qui arrivé en tête
des élections avec presque 50 % des
suffrages suivi du parti communiste le
parti libéral démocrate de russie russie
juste un nouveau venu dans la classe
politique du pays la formation nouvelles
personnes créée en mars 2020 je vous
propose d'écouter les réactions des
chefs de partis quant aux résultats des
élections
le parti communiste de la fédération de
russie avec les forces patriotiques
populaire a fait un très bon travail
nous avons été entendus tout d'abord par
la russie profonde dans les régions de
l'est surtout nous avons réussi à nous
allier et à réunir toutes les conditions
pour soutenir des candidats communs
selon les estimations préliminaires le
parti nouvelle personne aura 13 sièges
ou un de plus à la douma c'est bien le
monde de la politique n'est pas un
concept quantitatif mais qualitatif
c'est suffisant pour ébouriffés la douma
la situ les meilleurs cette année que
lors des élections de 2016 c'est plus
tranquille aucune violation particulière
n'a été enregistrée par le parti libéral
démocrate de russie mais en trois jours
il ya eu 2 127 infractions dont 86 grave
nous avons envoyé sa la cec et si
nécessaire nous l'enverrons au bureau du
procureur
la présidente de la commission centrale
électorale a confirmé huit cas de
bourrages d'urnes et les bulletins
concernés ont été annulés des enquêtes
ont été lancées quant à ces violations
et la pension va appeler les commissions
électorales locales à annuler les
résultats des élections dans les
circonscriptions où des violations ont
été constatés en tout la commission
centrale électorale a recensé plus de 25
mille bulletins annulés selon europe1
fillon devant aucune violation ne peut
être dissimulé dans le système actuel
électorale écoutez attendons qu'ils cela
garantit notre réputation si vous ne le
faites pas et si une plante qui nous
parvient et que nous constatons que vous
n'avez pas fait ce qu'il fallait nous
allons annuler nous mêmes les résultats
du vote
s'il y a des plaintes à votre niveau des
plantes concrètes officielle ne dressé
pas le bilan officiel avant de les
examiner tout publiquement ouvertement
en présence des plaignants
nous vous donnons du temps ne vous
dépêcher pas jusqu'à vendredi le jour où
nous allons annoncer officiellement les
résultats vous avez plus qu assez de
temps pour faire ce que vous avez à
faire
c'est notre réputation c'est la garantie
de la crédibilité des élections le
scrutin législatif russe a débuté le 17
septembre il s'est étalé sur trois jours
afin de limiter les risques épidémiques
les locaux vides 19 ces élections
interviennent un peu plus d'un an après
l'adoption de me vante d'amendements
constitutionnels qui ont
considérablement élargi le pouvoir des
législateurs russe et on reste en russie
où une fusillade a éclaté ce matin
l'université de pernes située à l'est de
moscou où elle a fait au moins six morts
selon l'onu c'est refuse de la santé
vingt-huit personnes ont été blessées le
tireur présumé un étudiant ouvert le feu
dans l'enceinte du bâtiment pas
d'information pour l'heure sur son
mobile ni sur son identité de la dîmière
poutine parle d'un grand malheur pour
tout le pays les précisions à moscou
d'entre eux clés de
l événement tragique s'est déroulée ce
matin à perm une ville de l'oural située
à 1200 km à l'est de moscou un individu
a ouvert le feu sur le campus de
l'université faisant de nombreux morts
et blessés les vidéos diffusées sur les
réseaux sociaux montrent des personnes
en panique fuir du bâtiment par les
fenêtres probablement pour tenter
d'échapper aux tueurs je vous propose
d'écouter quelques témoignages je n'ai
pas entendu deux coups de feu mais quand
j'étais sur le point de sortir du
bâtiment de l'université il y avait déjà
un groupe de gens qui commençaient à se
rassembler certains entraide autres
sortaient et alors que nous allions
sortir tout le monde s'est mis à courir
à l'intérieur du bâtiment si nous avions
quitté le bâtiment 10 ou 15 minutes plus
tôt nous aurions pu nous retrouver juste
là dans cette situation je ne sais pas
ça aurait été effrayant
une foule de gens courent et puis j'ai
vu un jeune homme avec un fusil qui
marchaient derrière eux est tiré je
n'arrêtais pas de penser que c'était des
exercices puis j'ai vu un homme qui
était tombé sur l'herbe qui était
allongé alors nous avons compris nous
étions trois dans le bureau que ce
n'était pas des exercices les quelque
chose de sérieux nous nous sommes
enfermés à l'intérieur dans le bureau du
doyen ça a commencé à 11h20 et nous y
sommes restés une heure jusqu'à 12h20
puis la police a frappé à la porte et
ils ont commencé à nous faire sortir
on était avec des amis à l'entrée
c'était avant les cours près de ma
voiture on a entendu des coups de feu on
s'est retourné il était là à 20 mètres
de nous avec un fusil de chasse nous
nous sommes dispersés on est allé dans
différentes directions il me semble que
personne n'a été touché dieu merci on
nous a tiré dessus mais il a touché ma
voiture tant mieux il n'y a que la
voiture qui a été endommagée nous sommes
tous sains et saufs
le tireur pour sa part été arrêté par
les forces de l'ordre qui ont déclaré
qu'il s'agissait d'un étudiant de cette
même université et qu'il était
légalement en possession d'une arme à
feu l'uss et a ensuite été prise en
charge à l'hôpital son identité n'a pas
encore été rendu public mais un peu plus
tôt dans la matinée un jeune homme de
cette université aurait écrit sur le
réseau social russe vkontakte sa volonté
de commettre une fusillade du show
il ne fait aucun doute que c'est aux
forces de l'ordre de livrer une
évaluation d'experts
apparemment on parle là d'un jeune homme
qui a commis un massacre parce qu'ils
étaient des accès d'une manière ou d'une
autre équipe
je pense bien sûr que les spécialistes
doivent s'occuper de cela et essayer de
comprendre ce qui est à l'origine de
cette tragédie
[Musique]
vous savez que beaucoup de travail a été
accomplie des modifications ont été
apportées à la législation
toutes les mesures nécessaires ont été
prises pour mettre en oeuvre les
instructions du président qui avaient
été donnés précédemment mais
malheureusement comme vous voyez la
tragédie a eu lieu et elle doit être
analysé
le président russe à d'ores et déjà
présenté ses condoléances aux proches et
familles des victimes tandis que le
ministre de la santé et le ministre de
l'éducation ont été dépêchés sur place
dans l'actualité également législatives
risque et au canada pour justin trudeau
les canadiens sont appelés aux urnes en
ce moment un scrutin anticipé lors
duquel les électeurs pourront soit
offrir un troisième mandat au premier
ministre libéral ou préférer
l'alternance avec le conservateur modéré
et lino toul les précisions de grégoire
dos et
le pari de justin trudeau était-il trop
ambitieux à la tête d'un gouvernement
minoritaire depuis 2000 19
le premier ministre canadien choisi il
ya un peu plus d'un mois de dissoudre le
parlement pour déclencher des élections
anticipées il a alors un objectif en
tête
convertir sa majorité relative en
majorité absolue afin de pouvoir
gouverner comme il l'entente je vous
demande d'appui un gouvernement
progressiste et ambitieux système de
santé fort du logement abordable un
environnement protégé
faites vous entendre
avant son ensemble mais cette stratégie
risque de tourner au vinaigre
incomprise par de nombreux canadiens
cette dissolution pourrait en fin de
compte se retourner contre eux trudeau
au coude à coude dans les sondages avec
son principal adversaire conservateur et
rino toul le premier ministre et ce fut
une pléiade de critiques à propos de son
bilan
accusé notamment de ne pas tenir ses
engagements sur le plan environnemental
il a dû faire face à la remise en cause
de sa politique dans plusieurs domaines
dossier afghan gestion de la pandémie ou
encore l'économie du pays
l'économie est en déclin la confiance
des entreprises est en déclin et
l'inflation augmente les conservateurs
du canada ont un plan pour remédier à
cela
qu'at-il fait
pire que rien pire
il a viré dans les attaques personnelles
les vidéotron pause divisant les
canadiens à l'américaine les attaques
trompeuses dans une élection qu'il a
déclenchées uniquement pour le bien-être
du parti libéral du canada
justin trudeau a eu l'occasion de se
défendre à plusieurs reprises la réalité
que monsieur o'toole n'a jamais comprise
c'est qu'on ne peut pas avoir une
économie forte sans s'attaquer aux
changements climatiques et vous demandez
comment nous allons convaincre le quart
des canadiens qui ne pense toujours pas
que le changement climatique est réel
monsieur o'toole ne peut même pas
convaincre ses propres troupes de la
réalité du changement climatique car ils
ont voté contre en convoquant ces
élections l'homme âgé de 49 ans expose
également à un risque majeur être
contraint d'abandonner son poste de
premier ministre
les autorités américaines ont commencé
hier le rapatriement de centaines de
migrants par avion depuis plusieurs
jours plus de 15000 personnes
originaires d'haïti sont massés sous un
pont au texas administration biden qui
fait face à une grave crise migratoire
également annoncé la fermeture partielle
de la frontière entre les etats-unis et
le mexique les explications de martial
peuvent y ont
embarqué de force à bord de charter
affrété par le gouvernement américain
méthode inédite depuis près de 20 ans
ils étaient des centaines ce dimanche à
retrouver le sol haïtien
expulsé du texas ces migrants n'ont pas
eu d'autre choix et dénonce la brutalité
des américains
quand nous sommes arrivés aux états unis
ils nous ont mis en détention pendant
quatre jours quatre jours sans se
brosser les dents quatre jours sans
douche tout ce qu'ils nous ont donnée
c'est de la nourriture regardez comme
nous sommes sales si on refusait de
monter dans l'autocar ou dans l'avion il
nous enfermer à l'intérieur d'un autocar
le temps qu'on se calme certaines femmes
ont même été frappé ils ont frappé les
hommes et les femmes
3000 300 migrants déjà été transféré du
camp de del rio au texas vers des avions
d'autres centres de détention selon les
services de la patrouille frontalière
3000 des quelques 12000 600 migrants
restants devraient être déplacés dans la
journée de ce lundi
ces expulsions accélérée ont été rendues
possibles par une mesure adoptée à
l'occasion de la pandémie de coronavirus
par donald trump en mars 2020 qui permet
de renvoyer immédiatement les migrants
en situation irrégulière sans qu'il
puisse demander l'asile et pourtant
l'objectif de centaines de migrants
haïtiens et africains restent de
rejoindre la ville de ciudad da cunha
dans l'état mexicain de coahuila à la
frontière du texas une église locale les
aiderait à préparer leur demande d'asile
tôt vendredi matin ils étaient plus de
500 à descendre des autocars qui les
emmenait vers la ville frontalière de
reynosa dans l'état de tamaulipas ce un
rêve que seuls les plus chanceux
parviennent à réaliser
on a marché on a couru et les agents du
service d'immigration était à nos
trousses les gens ne sont pas toujours
des gens bien il y en a aussi qui sont
malveillants et nous avons aussi été
escroqués dans certains pays on nous a
également pris notre argent nous avons
subi beaucoup de malheurs
une situation alarmante et embarrassante
pour le maire de la ville de del rio
je pense que le public doit savoir au
nom de la transparence ce qui se passe
dans la ville de del rio au texas et je
pense que la maison blanche doit
absolument nous aider à gérer cette
situation en temps réel et elle doit
dire au peuple américain ce qui se passe
sa frontière sud
l'administration byden a rappelé de son
côté que les frontières américaines
n'était pas ouverte aux migrants et
tente de décourager de se lancer dans ce
voyage périlleux
depuis l'entrée en fonction du nouveau
président américain en janvier dernier
plus d'un million trois cent mille
migrants illégaux ont été interpellés à
la frontière avec le mexique un chiffre
inédit depuis 20 ans
une rencontre pour apaiser les mémoires
60 ans après la guerre d'algérie
emmanuel macron a reçu aujourd'hui à
l'elysée quelques 300 harkis le
président français qui a annoncé un
projet de loi de reconnaissance et de
réparation à l'égard des deux cent mille
hommes qui ont bien combattu aux côtés
de l'armée française et maintenant qui a
demandé pardon au nom de la france et
c'est une première nicolas petit
après la guerre d'algérie les harkis ont
été placés en france dans des camps de
transit et de reclassement dans des
conditions de vie indignes
d'autres ont même été abandonné par
paris est victime de représailles dans
l'ancienne colonie française
soixante ans après la plaie n'est
toujours pas refermée
ce lundi devant certains d'entre eux et
leurs enfants emmanuel macron a souhaité
marquer les esprits au nom de la france
je dis aux harkis et à leurs enfants à
voix haute et solennelle
que la république a alors contracté à
leur égard une dette
aux combattants
je veux dire notre reconnaissance
nous n'oublierons pas
aux combattants abandonnés à leur
famille qu'ils ont subi les camps la
prison
le déni
je demande pardon
nous n'oublierons pas après la
reconnaissance par françois hollande en
2016 des responsabilités des
gouvernements français dans l'abandon
des harkis emmanuel macron souhaite
aller plus loin le président a annoncé
la présentation avant la fin de l'année
d'un projet de loi portant sur la
reconnaissance et la réparation à
l'égard de ses anciens combattants une
commission nationale sera mise en place
elle estimera notamment les demandes de
réparation des harkis de leurs enfants
et petits enfants qui vivent dans la
précarité
réclamée avec force par les associations
cette loi devrait être votée avant la
fin de la session parlementaire en
février 2020 de ce discours et les
nouvelles dispositions qui doivent s'en
suivre n'ont pas réussi à convaincre une
partie de l'opposition notamment marine
le pen
la générosité électorale d'emmanuel
macron ne réparera pas des décennies de
mépris ainsi que l'outragé commis par le
président à la mémoire de ces
combattants de la france accusée en 2017
avec d'autres de crimes contre
l'humanité à quelques semaines de la
présidentielle 2017 emmanuel macron
avait qualifié la colonisation française
de crimes contre l'humanité le président
entend encore participé à deux journées
mémorielle de la guerre d'algérie d'ici
à la fin du quinquennat la répression
par la police française d'une
manifestation d'algériens à paris le 17
octobre 1961 et la signature des accords
d'evian le 18 mars 1962 qui ont consacré
la défaite française en algérie autant
de rendez-vous sensible à la proche de
la présidentielle d'avril 2022
est avec nous dans quelques instants
notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français ce soir notre reporter katia
pique-niqué telle est la rencontre de g
amy chicheportiche propriétaire d'un bar
restaurant melun en région parisienne ce
patron souffre de la mise en place du
pass sanitaire une situation difficile
qui risque encore de durer puisque un
projet de loi visant à faire projet se
passe est en réflexion même s'il
pourrait être adapté à l'échelle locale
[Musique]
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions ou du
symbolisme en termes de technique ce
sera absolument parfait et ils veulent
une fanfare d'un possible pour la coupe
du monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power ici vous
regarde en termes d'argent le fou ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent si c'est que
dalle en fait ces pilotes donc si vous
voulez aujourd'hui être affiché à
travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde c'est rêver pour le qatar mais ce
qu on va reparler d'eux et encore pour
des raisons d'ailleurs plutôt mélioratif
plutôt peuple
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte l on soit vient de
l'ignorance aujourd'hui on est une
gauche l'extrême indigence et d'un
adolescent violent
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
est ce que vous répondez quand on vous
soupçonne et on soupçonne votre
industrie d'être sulfureuse d'industrie
elle est extrêmement contrôlée quoi
puisque reverse 50 5 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires à l'état et à la commune ils
sont donc très intéressé au fait que le
fonctionnement soit clean on fait
exactement comme les banques les
compagnies d'assurances loyer de
l'argent suspect nous sommes dans
l'obligation de le déclarer comment se
répartit 100 euros de mise globalement
aux machines à sou par exemple moi j'ai
dans l'obligation de vendre en moyenne
85% que nous on n'a absolument aucun
intérêt à ce que quelqu'un aille
raconter qu'il cheruiyot casino pas
certains pouvaient dépenser des sommes
extrêmement importantes allant jusqu'aux
millions d'euros aujourd'hui ça n'existe
plus on est beaucoup plus dans le loisir
aujourd'hui ce qui fait notre marge
c'est la fréquentation et le nombre
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission place
dans quelques instants à notre
incontournable rendez-vous qu'en pensent
les français ce soir la parole est
donnée aux travailleurs du secteur de la
restauration grandes victimes de la
pandémie de kobe 19 nous irons à la
rencontre de jérémy chicheportiche
propriétaire d'un bar restaurant à melun
en région parisienne quel impact a eu la
mise en place du pass sanitaires sur sa
clientèle quel avenir pour son commerce
son témoignage est à retrouver dans un
instant
[Musique]
mais on veut mais avant de donner la
parole aux français touchés de plein
fouet par la crise sanitaire et
économique on se penche sur la stratégie
du gouvernement face au co vide un
projet de loi pour prolonger le passé ni
terre au delà du 15 novembre est dans
les tiroirs c'est ce qu'a dit
aujourd'hui l'entourage du premier
ministre jean castex le texte pourrait
d'ailleurs être présentée le 13 octobre
prochain conseil des ministres
de son côté le ministre de la santé
olivier veyrat assure que l'utilisation
du pass ne serait pas pour autant
systématique partout en france des
questions qui seront au coeur d'un
nouveau conseil de défense mercredi
juliette lamy pour le point
il devait disparaître le 15 novembre
prochain mais pourrait finalement rester
en vigueur au delà de cette date un
projet de loi sera proposé à la mi
octobre pour prolonger l'application du
pass sanitaires en attendant l'exécutif
planche sur un pastelliste au réalisé
présenté mercredi prochain en conseil de
défense il serait alors mis en place
dans les régions ou départements où le
virus circule moins vite il y à une
réflexion sur la manière dont on peut
adapter les règles soient le pass
sanitaire peut être d'autres à la
situation locale et à l'évolution de la
situation locale une solution adaptée
sous-entendu par emmanuel macron jeudi
dernier puis évoqué par olivier ferrand
samedi lors d'une interview accordée au
parisien
si la situation continuait de
s'améliorer nous pourrions aller j'ai
progressivement les restrictions là où
le virus circule le moins d'abord puis
partout sur le territoire cet allégement
pourrait inclure le pas salutaire
vendredi dernier le cap des 50 millions
de primo vacciner a été franchi les
injections se poursuivre même chez les
plus jeunes en visite dans un collège de
loi ce lundi jean michel blanquer air
s'est félicité de la progression de la
vaccination dans les établissements
scolaires c'est très important qu'on
continue la dynamique qui est en route
on est en train de dépasser 69% des
principaux à 70% donc d'élèves de 12 17
ans qui ont eu déjà une première
injection et il faut continuer ainsi
puisque on sait bien que c'est cette
augmentation de la vaccination qui est
en train de créer en ce moment en france
tous âges confondus une baisse de
l'épidémie
d'après gabriel attal la situation
sanitaire s'améliore avec moins de 50
cas pour 100000 habitants dans une
trentaine de départements
mais les effets de la rentrée scolaire
sont encore redouter vendredi dernier
près de 3300 classes étaient fermés en
raison de cas de contamination ou kobe
19 et le passé ni terre qui n'est donc
pas près d'être abandonnée même s'il
pourrait être assouplie dans certaines
zones où l'épidémie recule alors qu'en
pensent les français
comment vivaient-ils ces mesures sur le
terrain nous sommes nous allés prendre
la température auprès des premières
victimes de ces mesures restrictives
souvent les restaurateurs à l'image de
jérémy chicheportiche propriétaire d'un
bar restaurant à melun en région
parisienne quel impact a eu la mise en
place du pass sur sa clientèle quel
avenir pour son commerce son témoignage
au micro de katia technique
je suis à melun aujourd'hui je rencontre
jérémy chicheportiche gérant du bar
monsieur le zinc bonjour jérémy comment
ça se passe pour vont sûrement pour
votre activité
c'est très difficile voilà on les paie
l'ouverture pas d'eau depuis le 1er août
on va dire le la mise en place de ce qr
code on perd on est environ une
trentaine de clients par jour d'accord
30 clients qu'on refuse ou à lattes
parce que tout simplement ils ont pas ce
qrcode vous perdez combien d'argent
alors par jour
on perd entre 600 et 900 euros par jour
voilà donc sur le mois ça fait un gros
chiffre est ce que vous avez trouvé des
solutions puisque le qr code est
obligatoire j'ai mis en place une
solution j'ai fait venir enfin j'ai fait
une demande à la rs d'une corde pour
devenir un centre de test
que j'installe donc deux fois par
semaine mercredi et le samedi donc ça
fonctionne bien on l'a concrètement à
chaque fois une vingtaine ou trentaine
de personnes qui veulent se faire tester
mais c'est pas suffisant comme vous
pouvez voir sur ma terrasse ya quoi ya à
peu près une 140 m 2 places assises
d'accord une fois installé complètement
il n'y a pas d'entrée il n'y a pas de
sortie donc concrètement le qr code
c'est très difficile de pouvoir le
contrôler
on n'a pas fait ce métier pour pour
contrôler les gens d'accord donc c'est
pas quelque chose que j'apprécie de
faire je le fais parce que c'est la loi
mais concrètement je trouve que ça n'a
aucun intérêt on enterrait si
on fait les choses sans intérêt pour un
patron de bar ça veut dire quoi mettre
en place la sécurité sanitaire pour les
clients bon déjà c'est
réorganiser la terrasse accord en
mettant plus de tame plus espacés
puisqu'on avait plus d'espacés d'année
la deuxième chose c'est qu'on a mis en
place un
un qr code sur lequel on peut nous aussi
on met en place des qr codes pour
pouvoir
concrètement commandées et payées
directement depuis sa table d'accord
donc pour éviter les contacts en réalité
j'ai racheté de lui des tables pour
réorganiser la terrasse ou simplement
pour pouvoir mettre plus de gens mais
avec plus d espace mans voilà c'est à
dire des coûts supplémentaires ça veut
dire des coûts supplémentaires
absolument après une année de fermeture
on va dire moi j'ai pas besoin de ça
alors j'imagine jeremic en cette période
de pandémie ça a dû être assez difficile
pour vous de gérer ce bar
mais elle est compliquée c'est une année
compliquée parce que concrètement j'ai
ouvert le 12 mars dernier en fin 2020
deux jours avant le confinement et le
premier confie de manger rien eu
complètement donc j'ai voyagé je suis
pas bête du tout j'ai dû prendre le pge
qui n'est franchement pas une aide parce
qu'il va falloir le rembourser ce prêt
je sais jusqu'au deuxième film en ou là
où on a été aidé mais alors c'est
toujours pareil ça va t'aider mais pas
tout de suite
j'ai presque attendu le mois de février
de cette année pour recevoir les aides
de l'état donc il a fallu assumer tous
les coûts depuis depuis l'ouverture ça
représente et combien de milliers
d'euros
franchement entre la perte de chiffre
d'affaires et le fameux la tréso il sait
auront au moins une soixantaine de
milles euros 60 kg c'est vrai que c'est
l'angoissé pendant pendant huit mois a
été donc vous avez laissé des plumes
autres que financières
oui mais je me suis séparé ma femme est
ce que tout ça ça a eu de l'impact sur
votre clientèle a été cassée dans notre
construction de clientèle d'accord vous
voulez perdre les gens il n'ya pas mieux
chocques on demande beaucoup aux
restaurateurs aux barres cette année de
faire des efforts des efforts des
efforts des efforts on ne fait pas ce
métier pour en permanence être les
agents de l'état quoi mon job c'est pas
ça mon job c'est de faire plaisir aux
gens qui passent un bon moment ça c'est
mon job voilà l'un concrètement je suis
pas celui que je voudrais être en ce
moment
jérémy est ce que vous avez réussi à
rétablir votre situation financière
après tous ces aléas bah non pas
concrètement j'ai pris un prêt en plus
donc j'ai des dettes en plus c'est pas
évident de travailler constamment comme
ça au jour le jour sans pouvoir faire
réellement de projection dès la saison
de divers va arriver pour moi ce serait
une première puisque je n'ai pas connu
la première donc je ne sais même pas à
quoi m'attendre vous voyez l'avenir
comment jérémy
je suis quelqu'un de positif donc
j'essaye de le voir bien d'accord parce
que sinon concrètement ça fait longtemps
que j'aurais fermé
lol l'établissement donc j'essaie d'être
positif
mais c'est vrai que c'est constamment
avec cette épée de damoclès de savoir ce
qui va nous arriver demain quoi c'est
qu'est ce qu'on va encore nous annoncer
de nouveau
donc c'est un stress permanent permanent
mais vous allez tenir je vais tenir
prêts je vais tenir malgré tout et parce
que je suis comme ça
face au désarroi de ce restaurateur la
stratégie gouvernementale est elle
vraiment la bonne pour lutter contre le
coc vite 19 faut-il proroger le passé ni
perdre ton adapter les restrictions en
fonction des chiffres zone par zone
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler joaquim
pueyo maire ps d lançons bonsoir
monsieur puyoô merci d'être avec nous il
veut d'amécourt à vos côtés porte parole
du mouvement de la ruralité bonsoir yves
d'amécourt merci également à vous d'être
avec nous on va commenter un petit peu
un ce qu'on vient d'entendre ce
restaurateur voilà qui vit assez mal
cette mise en place du pass sanitaire
mais d'abord ce débat qui est relancé
sur le pass and i ter à la faveur d'
emmanuel macron qui voudraient bien
l'assouplir dans certains territoires
alors qu'on parle de le prolonger d'une
manière globale quelle est votre
position il veut d'amécourt passe
sanitaire en local ou coup d'arrêt
finale pour vous
d'abord il faut noter la nouvelle
cacophonie du gouvernement avec un
ministre de la santé qui dit qu'on va
assouplir tout ça le ministre le premier
ministre qui dit qu'on va assouplir le
président qui revient derrière pour
expliquer au contraire qu'on va
prolonger et donc une fois de plus on
n'y comprend rien un ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui annonce des
fermetures de classes dès qu'on a un cas
positif alors que le conseil
scientifique préconise lui quand on a un
cas positif de tester la classe afin de
savoir qui est positif pour éviter de
fermer des classes et donc on est
toujours dans cette espèce de sentiment
que il n'y a pas véritablement de
stratégie et qu'on avance comme on dit
chez nous au doigt mouillé et jacques iv
lui on a vaincu
on va on va de toute façon aller plus en
profondeur dans ce débat joachim fuyons
justement sur ce diagnostic
comme le dit yves d'amécourt on est dans
une certaine manière dans le en même
temps
compliqués et contradictoire à mettre en
oeuvre sur le terrain c'est dû en même
temps des manuels macron je ne sais pas
mais on peut constater quand même que le
passé ni terre a été efficace et a
incité de nombreux habitants qui au
départ étaient sceptiques à se faire
vacciner on a quand même plus de 50
millions de français qui ont été
vaccinés donc c'est quand même positif
et moi je peut le remarquer cet été on
l'a maintenu toutes les grosses
manifestations sur la ville avec des
concerts je me souviens d'un concert
qu'à accueillir 1000 personnes va dans
une chose maximale de 1000 personnes et
tout le monde avait pas sanitaire donc
il ya eu quand même c'est une prise de
conscience et le pass and i ter à mon
avis a été efficace là il est vrai
qu'actuellement la pandémie est en recul
selon les chiffres que nous avons on a
effectivement actuellement 1800
personnes qui sont hospitalisées
1800 réanimation dont il y avait quand
même une baisse nette sont des chiffres
qui sont incontestables il nous constate
que 80% de ceux qui sont hospitalisés
n'étaient pas vaccinés donc le passe à
lithaire l'objectif c'était à la fois
d'assiter des français sur vacciner et
puis moi je le constate quand même parce
que il ya eu ce témoignage des
restaurateurs mais moi je suis maire et
président d'une communauté urbaine de
5000 habitants je vais souvent
restaurant et le week-end ils resteront
sont quant à eux relativement plein et
il ya eu une prise de conscience pas
salutaire quand même pose moins de
problèmes qu'il a posée lorsqu'on l'a
mis en place au départ alors
actuellement effectivement le taux
d'incidence diminue dans certains
départements je redemande département et
dans ma région on est à moins de 50 pour
cent mille habitants donc effectivement
on peut se poser la question s'il
faudrait pas adapté le pass and i ter en
fonction des territoires comme on
l'avait fait lors de la première vague
lorsqu'on mettait le confinement
fonction effectivement des départements
il y avait des départements qui étaient
vers d'autres qui étaient ouverts foncé
au rouge une question qu'on peut se
poser mais moi j'écoute les médecins et
les médecins sont quand même très
prudents ils nous disent attention on
n'a pas utilisé 80 % de la population et
on n'est pas à l'abri d'une nouvelle
vague cet automne
moi j'avoue que la place du gouvernement
je serais plutôt que d'en j'attendrai
d'une part les retombées de la rentrée
scolaire parce que la rentrée scolaire
la très peu de temps un quinze jours
donc on peut pas encore faire des
analyses attendent au moins quinze jours
battre en semaine pour faire une analyse
précise yves si effectivement la
pandémie en recul dans la question de
pyrite alizés le pass annie terre peut
se poser d'une manière objective yves
d'amécourt comme le dit à joaquim pueyo
d'une certaine manière ce témoignage
qu'on vient d'entendre ce restaurateur
d'une certaine façon c'est un cas isolé
pour vous vous l'avez constaté sur le
terrain les restaurateurs il ya aucun
problème ou comme le disait monsieur
chicheportiche voilà c'est une
contrainte économique et ça pèse aussi
sur ces commerçants qui ont été déjà
fragilisés
écoutez moi je suis dans une petite
commune de la gironde de 2900 habitants
et
le nez de 0,2 les trois restaurants delà
de la commune aujourd'hui souffre d'une
baisse de fréquentation très importante
et ils y vivent la même chose que ce
restaurateur c'est à dire qu'ils sont
obligés de dire à des gens de quitter la
salle de restauration parce que ils
n'ont pas le pass sanitaires je remarque
qu'aujourd'hui 21% des décès
hospitaliers ont chuté de 21% que les
les
86% des français éligibles aux vaccins
serre les plus de 12 ans ont eu leurs
premières vaccinations en fait je suis
assez d'accord avec monsieur le maire
d'alençon quand il dit que le pape
sanitaire a été utile pour encourager à
la vaccination parce qu'en fait le
gouvernement avait installé un tel doute
sur la vaccination que derrière il a été
obligé d'installer le pass sanitaires
pour inciter les gens à se faire
vacciner
j'aurais préféré qu'on encourage les
gens à se faire vacciner avec d'autres
types d'informations et on n'a pas eu
besoin du pass sanitaire en
responsabilisant les gens aujourd'hui
les courbes sont toutes décroissante il
ya trente-quatre départements qui sont
en dessous du seuil d alerte comme
l'orne et donc il faut absolument
encourager les gens et dire voilà on est
en train de réussir et donc il faut
enlever le pass sanitaire dans le plus
d'endroits possibles parce que sinon les
français ne comprendraient pas on leur
promet de mon miracles on leur annonce
et tout le monde le dit qu'on est sur la
bonne voie et on leur dit que après le
15 novembre on va renouveler pas
sanitaire d'ailleurs je voudrais dire à
ce sujet que le conseil constitutionnel
quand il avait été saisi par le
parlement après le vote du pass
sanitaires avaient bien signalé qu'il
fallait que le pass anitea il faudrait
en sortir et il fallait que les mesures
soient proportionnées avec le risque or
là le risque est en train de décroître
considérablement et si le gouvernement
veut prolonger le pass qualité il va
falloir qu'ils fassent des grandes
démonstrations pour expliquer pourquoi
il le prolonge effectivement j'imprime
puyoô c'est une question que beaucoup
dénoncent la question évidemment des
libertés publiques
vous en tant qu'élu quel est votre avis
là-dessus est ce que on est en train de
faire de la bulle de droite pouvoir au
sein du gouvernement clairement je
voudrais faire une observation il ya eu
ce week-end les manifestations autour du
patrimoine qui ont connu un gros succès
moi je le vois sur alençon les monuments
ou des visités et j'ai rencontré
beaucoup d'habitants et je pense que le
pas salutaire lorsque vous assistez à
une pièce de théâtre un concert ou un
match de football ou pour visiter un
monument on voit que les gens sont
détendus se dire qu'il ya des temps une
détendus ils sont détendus niveau
psychologique c'est à dire qu'ils sont
assurés ça s'est il faut le il faut le
dire quand même bizarre et une passe
sanitaires et on voit effectivement dans
les concerts il ya des manifestations
qui sont très positives le le deuxième
point effectivement la question que je
me suis posée c'est par rapport aux
libertés individuelles est ce qu'il ya
une traçabilité et comment cette
traçabilité où on peut on peut on peut
les repérer moi j'ai demandé à des
restaurateurs par exemple je passe avec
une passe sanitaires effectivement mon
nom est affiché ma date de naissance mon
anniversaire les mêmes et restaurateurs
qui m'a sauté mon anniversaire alors que
je ne connaissais pas du tout bon et on
m'a certifié que ces données effacées
mais c'est une question quand même qu'on
peut se poser parce qu'effectivement moi
je suis très attentif aux libertés
individuelles
le pass and iter doit effectivement être
cantonné bien encadré et il doit être
limité dans la durée et c'est peut-être
pour ça également comme vient de me dire
le président de la république et
d'ailleurs je voudrais lui dire que
j'étais maire rural pendant très
longtemps avant d'être maire d'alençon
est député et d'ailleurs je lui dis que
je comprends tout à fait le combat des
ruraux que je partage sur beaucoup de
domaines j'en profite pour lui dire ça
parce que je sais que c'est un
combattant pour défendre moon moral
le monde rural a besoin de combattants
actuellement comme les territoires
ruraux et comme les villes moyennes sont
petite parenthèse que je voulais lui
faire alors si effectivement on constate
que dans certains départements dans
certaines régions effectivement le le
taux d'incidence a vraiment diminué et
bien moi genre il faudrait envisager
effectivement de suspendre le pass annie
terre peut-être pas immédiatement
attendons un petit peu le retour de la
rentrée scolaire pour voir si
effectivement l'évolution se confiant au
niveau des jeunes il a effectivement
pourrait détendre ce pas sanitaires dans
les termes d'un département ou taux est
faible
merci mon point de vue
vous pardonnez moi jacques monsieur yves
d'amécourt vous êtes soutien de david
lisnard chez les républicains quelle
doit être la position pour vous de la
droite sur la question du pass
sanitaires et notamment lors de la
prochaine présidentielle si toutefois on
y est encore parce qu'on aimerait bien
s'en sortir évidemment de cette pandémie
j'espère qu'on en sera sorti et j'espère
aussi qu'on se servira de toute cette
période que on enregistrera un certain
nombre de choses et qu'on saura s'en
servir la prochaine fois que nous aurons
une pandémie parce que je j'entendais
l'autre jour un spécialiste des
pandémies et il disait c'est dommage que
au moment de la coronavirus on n'est pas
à ressortir les textes qui avait été
écrit au moment de la grippe espagnole
parce qu'en fait tout ce que tout se
passe exactement qu'au moment de la
grippe espagnole
et si on tait s'était servie de notre
histoire si on est s'était servie de
notre expérience on aurait peut-être
fait des choses différemment au moment
de des premiers masques au moment dé des
premiers confinement etc
joaquim pueyo on entendait tout à
l'heure la nouveau je crois que c'était
il d'amécourt dire là on a incité à la
vaccination mais vous parliez de la
rentrée scolaire quand on voit ici ou là
on a eu ce témoignage ici même sur rt de
deux parents qui préfèrent
enlever leurs enfants de certaines
activités de leur passion du foot du
judo le drone a eu lui même un papa qui
a préféré que son fils sciences de
collège alors qu'il voulait devenir
handballeur professionnel il pouvait pas
le faire dans le collège actuel parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas céder au chantage
un disque ce sont-là romo
ça veut dire quoi qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire vous
écoutez moi je je respecte les décisions
des parents je pense que nous sommes
dans une société de liberté et vous
indispensable pour faire des activités
sportives allemandes pour assister à des
matchs ou pour aller à des concerts ou
pour fréquenter des lieux culturels ça
permet quand même de protéger ceux qui
sont dans les enceintes alors quand des
parents ne le souhaite pas mais je gens
rencontrent également je les écoute je
les respecte également dans la décision
mais ceci dit je le dis franchement la
vaccination apporter beaucoup à pour
cette pandémie on le voit moi j'ai
confiance à la science j'ai confiance à
la médecine et les médecins que je
rencontre sont pas tous d'accord j'en
conviens mais 99 % des médecins
souhaite effectivement qu'un maximum de
français se fassent vacciner et
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas un aliment la
france regardez ce qui se passe en
italie on a imposé également le pass
annie terre pour aller dans les
entreprises par exemple
en espagne on vaccine beaucoup également
donc là il ya une panique pas sanitaire
mais
incite les personnes à les faire
vacciner moi je ne pense que le vaccin
c'est très important dans la mesure où
les vaccins sont quand même efficace
on est en train de vacciner les
personnes âgées pour la troisième dose
pour effectivement davantage protégés et
moi j'espère que
l'efficacité des vaccins c'est comment
on y arrivait ce que voilà le passé ni
terre et on l'a souvent dit une
vaccination obligatoire qui dit pas son
nom c'est c'est tous les débats je pense
je pense que effectivement si on atteint
80% de la population qui pourrait être
l'une ici là on pourrait se passer
facilement du passé ni cas je pense
qu'on va l'atteindre rapidement et puis
sur les territoires notamment les
territoires ruraux où on voit bien que
que le colis de s'estompe
rapidement on voit très bien là on
pourrait effectivement rapidement
prendre une décision pour suspendre pas
salutaire quitte à le rétablir si
effectivement la pandémie redémarre
sportif est bâti sur ce sujet là même si
les médecins vise attendait ne prenait
pas cette décision trop rapidement
attendons les analystes suite à la
rentrée scolaire qui donne un indice
important et ce qui peut rassurer
également les familles voilà moi je
fréquente bien sûr les familles je vais
visiter les écoles les cantines
scolaires le protocole sanitaire est
bien respectée je pense que ça rassure à
la fois les enseignants comme les élèves
mais quand on aura effectivement les
analyses très fines ou pourra se dire
bien voilà départements comme la manche
comme lotto me la normandie en général
vous pourrez effectivement suspendre le
pass annie terre et ça permettrait
effectivement à des restaurateurs qui
sont en difficulté de prendre à l'achat
du courage et beaucoup de petits hics
hilton nicole le mot de la fin pour vous
bien que vous soyez en vue réalité je
vais vous parler du métro mais tout de
même la colère de ce restaurateur elle
n'est pas aussi parfois fondées sur le
fait qu'il ya des incohérences on nous
demande un passani terre pour aller
dîner au restaurant y compris sur une
terrasse mais le métro bondé à paris on
en a pas besoin est-ce que s'il n'y a
pas une partie de la colère de certains
justement on y passe qui vient de là
bien sûr le ça fait partie des
incohérences dont je parlais tout à
l'heure et qui ont émaillé le débat sur
le court au navire russe depuis le début
de la pandémie et donc c'est tous ces
problèmes de 2,2 de communication de
discours
divergents qui font que les gens ont
perdu confiance si la confiance avait
été installé dès le démarrage je pense
qu'ils auraient eu moins de problèmes
pour pour convaincre les gens de se
faire vacciner je rappelle que la rn
messager a été
le découvreur de la rn messager a eu le
prix nobel je crois en 1965 donc c'est
pas quelque chose de nouveau et donc moi
aussi j'ai confiance dans la science et
derrière il faut il faut avancer mais
par contre il faut pas perdre de vue que
au fronton de nos mairies a écrit
liberté égalité fraternité
pendant cette pandémie je pense que la
liberté la fraternité doivent être deux
doigts devait être vraiment
respectée et défendu et il faut aussi
respecter et défendre les maires et donc
monsieur le maire d'alençon et là vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure de david
lisnard le maire de cannes qui étiez
d'ailleurs candidat à la présidence des
maires de france et donc les maires
doivent être respectées parce que ils
sont proches du terrain et ils peuvent
prendre des décisions que le premier
ministre depuis matignon ne peut pas
prendre merci à tous qu'elle est
vraiment mis en place des centres de
vaccination la déployé des moyens
considérables effectivement sur le
terrain bien on est attentif et c'est je
vous remercie de rappeler effectivement
le rôle des maires sont deux territoires
et vous savez il ya beaucoup de maires
peu importe les sensibilités politiques
on a fait le même travail n'a partagé
les mêmes diagnostic et on les change
beaucoup et où la dépassent
effectivement les clivages politiques
merci à tous les deux joaquim pueyo et
yves d'amécourt d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france et c'est la fin de
cette émission merci beaucoup de l'avoir
suivi rendez vous dès 20h pour un
nouveau numéro de mains en attendant
l'actualité continue toute la soirée en
direction de la province
[Musique]
le résultat d'un doigt peut réserver
bien des surprises pour mieux comprendre
où vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité les ide et
courageuse des mots qui comptent
en soi vient de l'ignorance aujourd'hui
on a une gauche prg extrêmement
violent
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
en suisse un fonctionnement politique
très particulier
elle permet à ses citoyens de se
prononcer sur les lois temps proposé et
même de les faire retirer éventuellement
en suisse il ya nos outils le premier
qui permet d'attaquer des lois l'autre
instrument c'est l'initiative populaire
qui permet d'être duire un nouvel
article de la constitution le fait même
que un sujet aride en votation signifie
qu'il ya un problème ce qui oblige les
les partenaires politiques à se remettre
autour de la table l'est elle ne
pourrait pas y avoir de dérive populiste
vu leurs proches de risque doit d'avoir
des votations sur des sujets dits
populiste est réelle mais je pense
malgré tout que le meilleur moyen pour
lutter contre le populisme c'est
précisément pour discuter et de trancher
je
[Musique]
la communication des modèles mapon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
pickton est-ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant poule il est où ça n'a
plus rien fait pour se rapprocher des
jeunes mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup
trop déconnecté de la sphère politique
il pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à
la politique dont il se désintéresserait
en lieu et place de politiser les jeunes
ça dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus kun est justement c'est une
nouvelle forme de communication assez
verticale utiliser des influenceurs pour
un sac hommes politiques personnelles
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme
c'est son travail en notre nom pour nous
et